und wir haben vorhin das thema begonnen
wer wirklich wahnsinnig spannende
wahlkampf hier in deutschland die spd
hat zum ersten mal die union
überholt in der letzten umfrage mit 23
zu 22 prozent und jetzt steht natürlich
die frage im raum wir haben den
ausschnitt vor hingehört sollte die cdu
csu
minute die pferde wechseln und
vielleicht doch auf söder setzen darüber
wollen wir jetzt sprechen sandra könnte
es die rettung sein oder ist es dann
vielleicht das komplette chaos sollte
söder jetzt übernehmen und schießt
laschet sich somit ins aus ist gibt dazu
zwei männer mit denen wollen wir
diskutieren
zwei männer zwei meinungen sie sind sich
oft einer meinung aber heute ist das
nicht der fall ich begrüße noch einmal
claus strunz unserem bild live chef und
hier haben wir jan schäfer unsere
politik schiff von bild ihr habt ein
bisschen zeit los geht's im duell
glaubst du dass es gestern ja schon
gesagt
eigentlich müsste jetzt ein frühstück
bereitet werden in nürnberg und armin
laschet müsste quasi markus söder an
tragen die kanzlerschaft zu übernehmen
ich glaube dass das mit dem frühstück
eine gute idee weil ich glaube auch dass
dieser frühstückstisch bereits gedeckt
war aber er war im april gedeckt und
wenn man jetzt an diesem frühstückstisch
tritt dann ist das brot verschimmelt die
eier sind vergammelt und der aufstand
ist ungenießbar es ist zu spät
viereinhalb wochen vor der
bundestagswahl kann man diese pferde
nicht mehr wechseln das wäre quasi die
kernschmelze in der union muss man sagen
so was wie ein fukushima moment die
union lebt davon dass sie verlässlich
ist das ist das elixier eigentlich
zumindest versucht sie das auszustrahlen
und wenn uns ein merkel wahlkampf auch
zu sagen ja sie kennen mich das war eine
botschaft an die wählerinnen und wähler
ob die gute schlägt eine andere frage
aber das ist immer nennt in der in der
in der cdu csu eigentlich drin diese
verlässlichkeit und jetzt die pferde zu
wechseln viereinhalb wochen vor der wahl
meiner meinung nach wäre das verheerend
katastrophal
wir sind interessante these also lieber
verlässlich untergehen als was wagen
nach vorne gehen ich finde dass in dem
bild des dürfe die union machst das
gesamte problem der partei das gesamte
problem der union ehrlich gesagt das
gesamte problem der deutschen politik
drin ist nämlich am bestehenden
festhalten bis es richtig schlecht wird
und deshalb ist mein rat an die union
wende müssen sie selber entscheiden
ehrlich gesagt muss dass armin laschet
entscheiden und das ist ja auch der der
schlüssel denn er hat das
vorschlagsrecht und ich stelle mir jetzt
mal vor armin laschet würde in großer
geste sagen es sind den wahlkampf
gestartet er hat das votum des
präsidiums
angenommen und als kandidat einen bisher
anstrengenden wahlkampf gemacht er
möchte die besten chancen für die union
und deshalb hat der microsite in
nürnberg besucht und ihn gebeten in die
kanzlerkandidatur einzutreten dann
konnte er sehr sehr sehr ehrenwert aus
der sache raus und die union wieder nach
oben warum bei markus söder wahlkämpfer
ist er ist der bessere wahlkämpfer als
armin laschet weil markus söder der
beliebtere ist das ist vielleicht nicht
in allen umfragen so aber jetzt bei den
unionswählern und unions unterstützern
also beim menschen die sich vorstellen
können union zu wählen da muss ja keinen
grünen rumkriegen und auch keinen linken
und vielleicht den ein oder anderen von
der afg aber auch nicht er muss ja die
unions wähler mobilisieren na ja man
wird ihm das wird ihnen glaube ich sehr
sehr gut gelingen denn er hat die
besseren argumente auf seiner seite er
ist neu geht frisch an den start er hat
noch wenige wochen aber er hat am
sonntag das erste von mehreren tree
allen also den direkten schlagabtausch
mit stolz und baerbock und wenn ich mir
vorstelle dass dort markus söder
auftritt dann ist das schmack ist drin
dann sind da ps der union auf der straße
während wenn armin laschet kommt dann
ist es halt wie es zuletzt immer war
einen wattebausch werfen zwischen
menschen die nur keinen fehler machen
wollen deshalb mein rat mein wunsch
meine empfehlung an die union jetzt
wechseln und angreifen stadt gemeinsam
untergehen ich habe unterschätzt die
häme die auf die union einprasseln würde
und natürlich muss armin laschet müsste
auch markus söder als kanzlerkandidat
viel mehr stimmen von anderen parteien
dazu wollen wir mit 22% wir haben die
zahlen ja gestern frisch bekommen kann
man nicht bundeskanzler werden das sehen
wir das heißt der kandidat der union ob
er nun markus würde oder armin heißt
muss unbedingt in den anna w lan lagern
punkten die frage ist jetzt wenn markus
söder antreten würden nehmen wir das
noch mal durch dann müssten alle
wahlkämpfer die bisher auf den
marktplätzen starten die haustür
wahlkampf gemacht haben und mit viel
werfe armin laschet geworben haben sich
möglicherweise auch anfeindungen anhören
mussten argumentieren mussten warum ist
es eine flasche geworden warum ist der
der bessere warum ist es nicht so dass
genau diese personen müssten jetzt
erklären vier wochen vor der wahl dass
sie eigentlich total falsch lagen dass
sie sich geirrt haben dass die argumente
völliger quatsch man diesen die sind
diesen diese kehrtwende hin zu bekommen
die halte ich für ausgeschlossen andere
frage warum geht denn markus söder nicht
hin und sagt armin laschet ich biete
mich dir als superminister an ich möchte
nach berlin das habe ich ja im april
deutlich gemacht im mai deutlich gemacht
und eigentlich den ganzen sommer über
mehr oder weniger auch deutlich gemacht
dass ich mich als den besseren
kanzlerkandidaten sehe und gerne etwas
für dieses land machen würde frage also
markus söder müsste aus münchen sagen
oder außen wer je nachdem ich stehe
bereit auch in einem kabinett von armin
laschet beispielsweise als superminister
also ja ich finde ja interessant dass du
quasi schon auf meine seite über
wechselst und sarges und sei nicht so
muss auf jeden fall dabei sein in der
nächsten regierung das wäre gut für die
union und meine these lautet wenn das
schon dabei ist dann sollte diese
regierung doch auch führen ich finde
auch das argument des späten wechsels
extrem zweifelhaft das wäre so als würde
ein fußballtrainer der sich für eine
aufstellung festgelegt hat von der im
training geglaubt hat das sei die beste
nach 80 minuten und 0 zu 1 oder 0
2-rückstand sagen ja die den karren im
dreck gefahren haben werden in den
letzten zehn minuten sicher noch
rausreißen das klappt selten man
wechselt dann doch frische spieler einen
wechsel torjäger ein mann wechselt leute
ein die das ding rumreißen können und
das alles trauen ich zitiere ja nur
sozusagen umfragen und meinungs-
befragungen das trauen die unions
unterstützer er microsoft so und jetzt
auch ein argument zu denen die es zu
mobilisieren gilt er muss ja gar nicht
bei anderen parteien groß leute
abluchsen er muss nur team mobilisiert
kriegen wir eigentlich gerne union
wählen würden aber die armin laschet
vertreten hat die eher verunsichert hat
die er mit seiner mit seiner art politik
zu machen er sogar in die arme der fdp
das würde ja wenigstens auch im eigenen
lager bleiben aber ich selber kenne
leute die sagen na ja also wir zum
ersten mal im leben kann ich mir
vorstellen die grünen zu wählen das
finden wir ganz schrecklich sagen die
ganz ganz schräg aber wie gut muss bevor
der essen deren mannes macht machen wir
lieber das und für alle reichen um aus
22 28 zu machen und das würde ich mal
aus wieder zum aber wie gut das geklappt
hat mit den einwechslungen du hast das
beispiel gebracht haben wir gesehen bei
der weltmeisterschaft bei der
europameisterschaft ökonomie vaart
eingewechselt und es hat nichts gebracht
überhaupt nichts das ist ein argument
dass eine hoffnung szabo matt ist könnte
so kommen keiner weiß ist und ich glaube
es ist viel besser in diesen vier wochen
vor der wahl er zu sagen okay wir wissen
das kind ist in gewisser weise in
brunnen gefallen der fehler wurde dann
offenbar im april gemacht aber jetzt in
so kurzer zeit zu wechseln das wäre
falsch ich stimme dir vollkommen überein
der wahlkampf den armin laschet bisher
gemacht hat der ist sicherlich etwas für
die geschichtsbücher aber in negativer
hinsicht ein so dass derlei doch er hat
bild eher schlecht gespielt er hat mir
schlecht hat ein täter hatte loren und
verloren und verloren und verloren und
verloren aber es sollte schon mal zu
ende machen jedoch völlig verquere logik
seiner es gibt eine einschätzung vor aus
der union die cdu csu oder vor allem die
cdu hat sich geeinigt auf amila als
kanzlerkandidaten man hätte vielleicht
im matsch und man kann das keiner
korrigieren und richtig aber die frage
ist doch mal korrigieren außerdem armee
lasch ist ein teamspieler was armin
laschet bisher falsch gemacht hat ist
oder was das ganze team von ihm falsch
gemacht hat ist er hat bisher kein team
aufgestellt markus söder sieht sich als
entscheidende figur innerhalb der cdu
csu er muss in dieses team rein
friedrich merz muss eine viel stärkere
rolle spielt also armin laschet muss
eigentlich das machen was er in
nordrhein westfalen erfolgreich gemacht
hat nämlich ein team um sich scharen das
aus experten besteht aus guten männern
aus guten frauen aus wirklichen machen
und können und das ist das was ihm
bisher im wahlkampf fehlt das ist auch
das warum es markus söder immer noch so
leicht hat in diese phalanx einzubrechen
sich immer noch als der große starke
quasi retter der union dazu stehe ich
bin mir gar nicht sicher ob markus söder
das so gut hinkriegen aber die und das
ist in der union sind markus söder
ausgesehen
dass seine partei nicht in der lage ist
eine entscheidung zu treffen um
deutschland in die zukunft zu führen und
in letzter minute wird dieses pferd
gewechselt das ist kein zeichen von
seriosität und verlässlichkeit das ist
genau das gegenteil
sekunden zeit jetzt doch noch eure
argumente
das argument ist völlig klar wenn die
union eine firma wäre die an der börse
ist und man aktien kaufen könnte würde
der wert der union aus meiner sicht
massiv steigen wenn sie auf den bus
setzen in der politik heißt es ist
steigen die umfrageergebnisse und es ist
am ende ein besseres wahlergebnis wer
sich das entgehen lässt muss sich nach
dem 26 september wirklich fragen lassen
ob er sich nicht an der union und ihrer
zukunft vergangen hat amila dass wir mal
ein argument muss jetzt seine
zwangsjacke ablegen er darf keine
rücksicht mehr nehmen im wahlkampf
wieder auf die bundeskanzlerin noch auf
irgendwelche bundesminister noch auf
irgendwelche befindlichkeiten in der
partei das hat er bisher zu viel gemacht
er muss jetzt den wahlkampf machen den
er auch wirklich machen will mit dem er
deutschland nach vorne bringen will und
führen will ansonsten hat er da gebe ich
das recht keine chance aber das muss er
jetzt tun
[Musik]